I've been really hesitant to make this
video because I know that it's going to
make a lot of people upset but I really
feel like it's important to make this
video because it could help people that
are stuck in legalism and deception and
a false
gospel so for the honor of the name of
Jesus let's talk about how I figured out
that I was raised in a cult
[Music]
welcome to Celebration state where we
help Christian creatives to grow in
their creativity and in their love for
God so a lot of times we talk about on
this channel how to create art with God
how God gave us the ability to do that
and we can Unite with him we can make
that a process of prayer and he can
create some amazing things through us
but today I'm going to talk very
personally about my own experience and
how I discovered that I was raised in a
cult so right off the bat when we get
started there's going to be some
confusion because the cult that I'm
referring to is sth day adventism and
when I say cult what I mean by that is I
don't mean that they secretly wear a
bunch of hoods and robes and they have
secret handshakes or you know strange
things like that no human sacrifices I'm
not talking about that what I'm talking
about is 7th day adventism is a false
gospel
it's a different Jesus it's a different
way to
Salvation and not a lot of people know
that so right off the bat when I say I
was a Seventh Day Adventist I discovered
that I was raised in a cult I know that
some of you are going to be confused so
we'll get into that and I plan on making
more videos in the future that go into
the ins and out of what exactly makes
something a false gospel what exactly
makes something not aligning with Jesus
and the truth of who he is as revealed
in his word but the really strange thing
is that adventism has sort of snuck
under the radar so that most people
think that seventh day adventism is just
this very rule focused denomination of
Christianity and let me tell you right
now that is not the case and believing
that causes way more harm than good it's
not helping the Adventists by trying to
welcome them in you're actually harming
them because they don't know the real
gospel and they're not getting it where
they are so for us to call Adventist
Christians is really harmful so getting
into my story a little bit when I grew
up I was a devout Adventist I wanted to
love God and I considered myself an
Adventist a very serious Adventist until
the time time that I was 14 years old
and at this point not because I was
angry with anything about the Adventist
Church but because I was actually
exposed to some atheistic literature
from someone that was very close to me
and because I didn't have didn't have
any reasons to believe in God I ended up
becoming an atheist and so but I didn't
have some of the common you know Church
hurt stories that cause people to want
to become an atheist and some of the
bitterness that is there in a lot of
atheists it was not there in me until I
felt a bitterness that I had been what I
felt was lied to my whole life when i
really grabbed on to the atheist
ideology so to kind of fast forward a
little bit quickly atheism was a very
dark period of my life after a time I
became agnostic because I started
questioning the logic of atheism
thinking things like well how can we
really know that there's no God and the
answer is you can't actually really know
so I started to become skeptical of my
skepticism so when I became an agnostic
which just means basically very
simplistically that you don't know if
there's a God or not it freed me to
pursue God and try to find out what the
truth was without this sense of judgment
or just feeling like that was so
ridiculous and foolish and and so what I
ended up doing was I went to uh a
Catholic mass trying to figure out if
there was any light there spiritual sort
of light and I even went back to the sth
Day Adventist Church and I even joined
the choir there they didn't ask if I was
an Adventist H which is very interesting
but they so they allowed this sort of
agnostic girl with a lot of confusion
and questions to come in and be in their
choir and so I was looking for God but I
hadn't settled on what that meant yet
and during this time I had a lot of
people that wanted me to be a lot of
things I had a boyfriend who wanted me
to become Greek Orthodox I had a friend
from college and she wanted me to become
new age I had other people that wanted
me to stay atheist or go back to being
atheist and so I had sort of all these
things pull in and as I'm getting closer
and closer to God and to calling myself
a Christian I have in my heart that I
don't want to be Greek Orthodox I don't
want to be Catholic I don't want to be
7th Day Adventist I just want to be
Christian and this was a very strong
pull that I had in my heart to the point
where I would leave these other
relationships so that I could become a
Christian and if they were standing in
my way of doing that then I would end
those relationships and that can only be
God and that I'm so thankful for that
but I didn't at that time so I became a
Christian and I was just this stumbling
ridiculous baby Christian who thank God
I found a passionate Christian church
and I'm just so thankful that I ended up
reconnecting with my old friend who's a
Christian and she was on her way to
church and I said you know I'm really
looking for a church do you know of a
good one she's like come on with me and
Samantha Naple I'm so very thankful for
her but during this time I didn't have
any ill will toward any of these
denominations as they would like to call
themselves I just felt like this is for
me I want to be a Christian and I just
didn't know a whole lot and the people
around me they also didn't have any
reason as far as they knew to think
badly of Adventists in fact they also
just considered them sort of a silly
branch of Christianity that's a little
too legalistic come on you guys like
stop being so serious and join the fun
that was kind of how they were looked at
with the people that were around me and
so there were some red flags that were
going off as relates to adventism um as
I began actually reading the Bible and
things that in my early walk with God
they stand out now but at the time I
just kind of brushed them off because I
didn't really know what I was Finding so
the first big red flag for me was that
when I started reading the book of
Galatians in which Paul is being very
strict and very serious about these
people that are trying to get the people
in galatia to act more Jewish to they
were the judaizers and they're trying to
get them to observe more the law as I
read that book for the first time in my
life ever with these new baby Christian
eyes I thought to myself wow it would be
so great if Adventists could read this
book this is this would be a really
great book for
them and most people that come out of
adventism would agree with that
statement that Galatians would be a
really great book for Adventists to read
now that would be great for anybody to
read Galatians but why specifically that
group of people why would that be good
for them to read because they are
following the different gospel that Paul
warns about in that very book and they
need to have the light of the true
gospel which is not about rules and
regulations from the old Covenant anyway
so that was the first red flag the other
red flag for me was that I would
inwardly cringe and just sort of
struggle so much when whenever the
Sabbath was mentioned I was going to a
church that observed worship on Sunday
and I loved my church and I didn't see
anything wrong with them doing that but
inwardly I felt condemned if I didn't
worship on Saturday and I was wrestling
with that I trusted my leaders at the
time now I have a very robust argument
on why Sunday is the best day for
worship but also that every day is a day
that we worship God so it doesn't
actually matter and we can talk about
the historical argument the scriptural
argument cuz it's all there let me
assure you if you're just coming out of
out of adventism it's okay there are
arguments so it's going to be okay you
don't have to cling to that day of
Saturday worship but I didn't know all
of that and so whenever it would talk
about Jesus going into the synagogue or
things that related to to jewishness to
Judaism I would inwardly get sort of
afraid and condemned because I was
worried okay am I supposed to be going
to church on Sunday or should it be
Saturday is this okay I don't know and
it was this bound feeling it was this
tied up feeling of the legalism that I
had been raised up in coming back up
again in me so looking back I can see
all of that and say okay this is not
voting well for not only adventism but
also for
its lasting effects on me and those were
red flags that I just experienced and
lived through I kind of just thought it
was a me thing like a weird me thing but
I was also surrounded by people that
believed adventism was just another
denomination and that it was fine and so
I wasn't getting the support that I
needed the help and understanding the
actual truth of what the word says about
Sabbath in the New Testament in the new
Covenant and how Jesus is our Sabbath
rest now all of that was not something
that anyone brought me through or helped
me out of because people didn't even
know that they needed to help me out of
that so fast forward a few years I'm
having my life amazingly transformed at
this Christian Church people around me
are being transformed my family's
beginning to be transformed I meet and
Mary my amazing husband we've been
married for over 16 years uh this was a
long time AG go so then some people that
are very close to me who had had their
lives beginning to be changed in certain
ways you could say or they'd at least
seen the change in me they ended up
going headlong into different forms of
deception uh turning away from
Christianity into these these different
forms of new age or spiritualism not
following God and I began to need to Out
of Love have these really difficult
conversations with them trying to pluck
them out of the fire because they were
both just they were kind of headed in
opposite directions but both of them
were away from God and so as I'm having
these difficult conversations with them
and
hearing their arguments I realized that
although I have a very strong
relationship with God in the world of
apologetics and having good arguments
and defenses things like that I did not
have as much as I should have had for
those moments and so just out of
necessity I needed to begin doing my
research and so I went on this journey
with God where I started reading and
mostly watching videos of Christian
apologists or people interviewing people
that had come out of Cults you know
researching The New Age researching
Buddhism researching conspiracy theory
kind of stuff and all those things and
as I'm researching all these things I
find adventism on this
list I was watching a YouTube podcast
interview of a show called cultish and
they had these two women come on and
discuss how adventism the history of it
is just in meshed in the Cults and as it
grew and over time it sort of was able
to hide the fact that it was a cult and
we'll talk more about this later in
future videos so this video right now is
not an argument against adventism I can
make videos like that in the future if
you all are interested but these women
were just going through plainly how
adventism is a false gospel and I was
thinking yeah that's true yeah I
remember hearing that yeah that's true
is that really true and doing research
into those parts the is that really true
and so I was really sort of shocked
and I still don't have all the words to
describe all of the the weirdness of
that feeling and so what I ended up
doing was just doing research into all
of the history of it to confirm all of
the crazy things that I heard which were
so off-the-wall and turned out to be
true but also just reflecting on how
much sense it
made because the gospel that they
presented was so very different it's so
very Works based now Adventists will
never tell you this which does not mean
that they're not cult followers does not
mean they're not following a false
gospel if you're more comfortable with
that terminology so the three big things
that make adventism a cult which we'll
talk about more later as I mentioned is
that they don't really think that you're
fully saved now in fact that's not a
terminology that I ever heard growing up
oh I got saved you know because they
think that Jesus is monitoring your
every move now and seeing if you can be
perfect and that's called the
investigatory judgment so there's
there's that element there's they don't
believe that Jesus is eternally the Son
of God they think he ascended to that in
fact the founders of adventism did not
believe in a trinity this is a really
big deal and besides all of that it is a
works-based gospel so they believe that
if you are doing these specific things
these specific laws that they take from
the Old Testament and modify them they
think that if you do those things such
as Sabbath keeping and dietary laws that
you can be saved and all of this is so
anti- God it's anti-biblical when I
discovered this and I'm not I don't want
to be so dramatic but it's almost as if
you were the victim of a
crime but nobody believes that it
happened nobody believes that you were
the victim of this crime everybody knows
the person that you're saying did the
crime and they think think that they're
great they're a wonderful respectable
member of society and so how could they
ever do that and thank God I have met
some people that um that do see they do
understand the false gospel that's being
presented there and there is so much
encouragement on just here on YouTube of
people coming out of Cults and coming
out of adventism that has been just so
great and I'm so thankful for my husband
who understood as well and who was going
on this journey with me and listened to
all of the research that I was Finding
and that because there wasn't in my area
just like a a former Adventist support
group or something like that that I
could join really the thing that
strengthened me was my relationship with
God but also and just in seeing his his
Sovereign plan for me to do all of that
research and to come to know what it
really was that I was raised up into but
also then bolstering strengthening my
understanding as to why adventism is
wrong as to why their beliefs about
Jesus in The Gospel and salvation are
wrong but also doing the research and
understanding historically and
scripturally why every day is sacred to
God now and why Jesus is is actually our
Sabbath rest if you read in Hebrews 3
and 4 Jesus is our Sabbath rest now we
can't say it's one day anymore you guys
that's just a shadow Jesus is our
Sabbath rest and I'm going to talk about
that more in the future I would love to
because I get so impassioned about it
but but the knowledge of that has been
what's really sort of protected me now
because out of love I've needed to have
some really difficult conversations uh
with my family and people that were
around me because I needed to warn them
that if they were still a part of
adventism it's not a true gospel so if
you were a former Adventist or if you
came out of any other sort of false
gospel let me know in the comments I
love interacting with people like that I
just feel such this common bond with
them but also in general if this video
blessed you please like this video and
consider subscribing it helps us to
reach more people with the truth of
God's word and the freedom that he has
for us in the New Covenant and if you
disagree with what I've said in this
video you are allowed to disagree but
just understand this video is not
evidence that I'm presenting you as to
why people should not follow adventism
this is just a story about my own
experience and what it's been like for
me
and if you're interested in an argument
for not being an Adventist or for why
worship on Sunday um is actually a great
and wonderful thing and is scripturally
based let me know I'd be happy to
present that in a full video for youall
and it'll be great thanks so much for
watching be so blessed
[Music]